an dieser schule in vietnam werden
sprung kicks und akrobatik unterrichtet
wo wien am nennt sich die traditionelle
kampfkunst und die soll den schülern vor
allem bei einem kampf helfen dem gegen
die videospiel sucht ich lebe jetzt ein
geordnetes leben und versuche meinen
eltern nicht zu widersprechen
ich habe die spiele auf gegeben und bin
ein neuer mensch geworden nicht jemand
der sich aus dem haus schleicht um
spiele zu stellen
an der schule wird nicht nur video
spielsüchtigen geholfen
auch die drogen oder alkoholprobleme
haben die schüler müssen persönliche
probleme überwinden indem sie kampfsport
machen
damit werden sie alte angewohnheiten und
faulheit los politische disziplin und
kampf kunst hilft den schülern dabei
besser zu werden
meistens bleiben die schüler zwei bis
drei jahre an der schule genug zeit die
schlechten gewohnheiten abzulegen